and if this reliance on numbers and
analytics and formulas was foolproof the
draft would not be the crapshoot that it
is and the jets found out the hard way
three years ago when they made the
all-in move going from six to three
giving up three second round right hey
there you go jump up three spots sam
darnold not the guy not the franchise
quarterback they've been searching for
since joe namath
darnold officially introduced yesterday
as the new quarterback of the carolina
panthers
he talked to reporters about the reality
of the new york jets deciding after only
three seasons that they no longer wanted
him here's darnold from monday
before the trade happened i always
thought that you know
i could make it work in new york
just being honest um you know i really
did and
like i said i mean my goals never
changed even though there was
speculation about me getting traded
i always
you know believed that i could make it
work and
that we were going to get pieces and
just be able to you know win some games
in new york and go to the playoffs and
eventually win a super bowl when i heard
the news that they wanted to trade me um
it was tough you know anytime you you're
not wanted somewhere that's always you
know a tough pill to swallow
yeah look that's how it worked they
wanted him until they didn't and you
know what the panthers want him until
they don't he should talk to teddy
bridgewater about how you go from being
wanted to unwanted in carolina in one
year and that could happen even though
his salary when they pick up the option
for 2022 will be fully guaranteed at
18.858 million they still could decide
after one year donald's not the guy this
is just the next stop in this
never-ending quest by david tepper the
owner of the team to find a franchise
quarterback teddy bridgewater didn't
work sam darnold let's see what happens
if that doesn't work we'll move on to
the next guy and that's what darnold
needs to realize there's no grace period
for him in carolina it's sink or swim
because if you don't swim you're going
to go on to the next team we're going to
be having the same press conference
unwanted by the panthers now i'm wanted
by whichever team he lands with next
probably not as a starter if this
happens again after only one year chris
yeah that's right i mean yeah if he if
it doesn't work out here yeah he's going
to be relegated to backup bill until he
can prove himself as a starter again but
he's in the spot i think that you know
really
is he's in a spot or a position to
succeed and flourish i do believe that
again i'm a believer in sam darnold i
think i i for me i've seen enough to
think hey you can win with this guy you
could go to the playoffs you can make a
playoff run he can do some damage that
way i think it's the perfect marriage as
far as a player how he fits in the
offense the skill set around him i think
there's a good opportunity here we could
see like a
a sam darnold aka ryan tannehill
type career transformation where it's
like the same thing you just go it
wasn't really that bad in the last spot
it was a lot of crap around him and as
we know that can lead to crappiness out
of your play and that's what happened to
tannehill with miami you know so i would
not be shocked if we saw a similar story
there with you know that offense and
some of those guys and what they're
building there in carolina i mean they
they got it going i like the moves they
make and i'm happy for sam donald he's
in a place that really wants him and i
think he's got the pieces around him to
to kind of let it fly
and the difference is tannehill was in
miami for seven years before the
dolphins moved on darnold's only been in
the nfl three seasons yeah he's still 23
years old he's got a long way to go a
lot of chapters left in his nfl book and
and we could we could see where it goes
but
but the cautionary tale is teddy
bridgewater because
they can quickly fall out of love with
you in carolina for now they are in love
with them here's matt rule coach of the
panthers talking about his faith in his
new quarterback sam darnold
we believe in sam we believe in his
skill set we believe in his approach
as you talk to people that
know him
he's tough-minded he's competitive and
um
you know we're really hopeful that this
will be a you know a great place for him
and this will be a tremendous time for
him in his career
matt what uh physical skills still jump
out to you when you watch sam darnold on
tape despite you know
the documented struggles over the last
three years
um
i think uh when you see his arm talent
his ability to you know i think i don't
think there's a game that you watch
where he doesn't make a play that
makes you say
that you know there it is
i can fit the ball into tight windows
can create with his feet he moves around
a ton
you know he uh
creates plays with his legs extends
plays with his legs
and then you can just kind of see and
feel his grittiness and his toughness so
i think um i think his arm talent his
movement or are a great fit for the
players that we have here that he'll be
playing with
i still can't shed the memory of matt
rule last year telling us how he's
looking forward to coaching cam newton
but
uh
look it's it's
sam dartle has not done enough to be
dubbed a franchise quarterback you can
point to certain things and you can pull
out certain plays and the panthers
social media teams done a good job of it
over the past few days of highlighting
the good from sam darnold the problem is
this isn't like golf where you have that
one good shot or maybe it is you get
that one good shot around you otherwise
shot 150 but you had that one good shot
it's about
having
more plays
that help your team
than moments that hurt your team because
in balance you're judged not by being
able to pull out
a flash or two on film and say hey you
made a good decision there you got to
make the good decision far more often
than not you got to put the team in
position to gain yards chew up the clock
score points more often than not and
clearly he wasn't able to do it whether
it's his fault the guys around him the
coaching whatever we're going to find
out the guy clearly has the skills to be
an nfl quarterback the question is can
he perform at a sufficient level on a
consistent basis
and how much of it again is him versus
what was around him we're going to find
out great test great experiment we'll
find out this year no yeah we are we're
going to find out a lot and there's not
going to be a lot of excuses i mean
there's there's not you're right there's
talent it's mccaffrey it's robbie
anderson it's dj moore who's a superstar
receiver you know it's a pretty good
offensive system you know their
offensive line
should be better you know they got a
good right tackler taylor moton they got
greg little you know they drafted a few
years ago should be left tackle could
they use some interior offensive lineman
sure
but may i i just i just think you know
again
sam darnold was never put in a position
to answer some of those questions you
know that you're talking about mike
you're right that's where it's tough
with him you know it just wasn't a
position to succeed and you can't
realistically sit there and blame him
for like oh hey you're a rookie can you
carry us and play perfect and make every
perfect decision and then have to make
like some amazing plays every game with
not a lot of guys that are very good
around you can you do that for us and
then maybe we can win or actually not
even win just be competitive that's
that's really what he was asked to do
and that's where it's unfair that's
where it's it's hard to
you know evaluate him to a degree
because of some of the bad spots he was
constantly put in but he's quick he's
really got great feet in the pocket
he can move around and throw under
pressure because he's got a quick
release and because of those feet mike
he is tough you could see there even in
that press conference he's honest he
makes no excuses you like that about him
and
you know for for him personally i mean
you know listen mike you look at
carolina right and where they're picking
what are they they're number eight right
eight they could be in a spot where
sam darnold yeah now that they have
addressed the quarterback you know i
don't think they're drafting a
quarterback at number eight that would
be one of the dumber moves of the
offseason if that happened i'll just say
that right off the bat
but
they could be sitting there at number
eight going
wait we could take the top corner on the
board it's a big need for their football
team or wait is that kyle pitts on the
board did any of those teams take kyle
pitts yet oh no okay we'll add them to
our offensive arsenal and now you have
that to go along with the two receivers
and running back i mean they could be
sitting there really pretty like i'm i'm
really excited about what caroline is
doing as a football team and how they've
kind of orchestrated their roster
matt roll said yesterday they're in a
position now to take the best player
available at number eight which implies
look you got some reaching for
quarterbacks that happens at the top of
the draft we've talked about that a lot
yeah the fact that the quarterback
position is so important to winning and
the longevity if you get lucky with that
lottery ticket that you scratch off and
it says franchise quarterback you've got
the position solved for 10 15 maybe up
to 20 years one last thing about darnold
though with the jets yeah and this is
what zach wilson or whoever is going to
step into i think with each passing year
with each roll of the dice that fails
there's more and more pressure on the
next quarterback to finally become the
guy and there's going to be a ton of
pressure on zach wilson or whoever the
second overall pick is and yeah it's a
great market and you're going to have a
lot of attention you're going to have
off-field earning
opportunities but you got to get it done
and the patience isn't there like it
used to be you got to get it done
quickly or you'll be thrown overboard in
three years just like sam darnold was
because if the team continues to stink
they're gonna be back in position to get
one of the best quarterbacks let's go
scratch a new lottery ticket which is
exactly what the jets are gonna do yeah
no you're right and you know hopefully
they're not gonna make that same damn
mistake once again they've tried to
improve their offensive line
they signed a corey davis and free
agency to help out hopefully that young
quarterback they do have denzel mims who
was a second round pick last year you
know to help out the wide receiving
quarter so we'll see where it goes but
yeah you just hope like for as you're a
jets fan that history doesn't repeat
itself you're gonna draft one of these
guys in the top five
you gotta make it happen they can't just
make it happen by themselves and we've
really seen that with all the great top
quarterbacks in the history of the nfl
the majority of them have been
surrounded by really good talent early
on in the career and that helps them
build confidence become a better player
and then lends them to being a superstar
when they get in the middle of their
career and i just i hope joe douglas and
company realize that and i think they do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports